- We're gonna do the egg test.
- I don't wanna risk crushing an egg
all over my hand and mattress
and sheets and everything,
so I kinda split the difference.
- Pushing down on the egg.
It's all the way down!
(plastic crinkling)
(laughing)
We're going to be using Purple products
for a week to see if it
helps our sleeping problems.
(light plucky music)
- I have a little bit of sleep trouble.
I have lots of old basketball
injuries and stuff,
I've broken both my ankles before.
- Seven years ago, I actually fell
through a trap door,
and I caught my arm on the stairs.
Basically I have whiplash and
pinched nerve in my check.
- Like my back will hurt, my neck hurts.
And I wake up a lot and I just, I'm achy.
- So the first thing is when
you actually get the mattress,
it weights a million pounds.
It's so much heavier than it looks.
When you get it actually on the bed,
it's like in this cool shrink-wrap.
It's growing.
It's so weird.
(rustling)
- Okay, this is cute.
Oh my God, this feels amazing.
- The pillow is very comfortable.
It also weighs 40 pounds
and is made of materials
that you would never
expect to see in a pillow.
What is this?
This is so trippy.
So weird.
- Oh, shit.
Oh my God.
Oh, I am sweating.
Oh my God, Pete, tell
me, what do you think?
The pillow feels like a butt.
(laughing)
It feels like a butt.
So it feels like you're just
napping on someone's butt.
Last night I tried to go
to bed at nine o'clock.
And it worked.
- My back feels better
than it normally does.
I did wake up a few
times during the night.
But nothing too crazy.
- First night I had a
really bad crick in my neck.
Maybe it's just getting
used to the pillow?
And I think it was also too tall.
It came with these pads
that made it taller and thicker.
And the first night I
realized I didn't like that.
So I took those out and it
was much more comfortable.
It was perfect for my neck.
- Part of this video should
be that we get to stay home
and be on the bed all day.
That's...
That would be a good test.
- When I did open it, mine
had powdery stuff inside.
I think it's from the rubber a little bit.
When they cut it or something?
There's kinda like a natural,
I don't know what it was,
it wasn't a big deal.
But it was kinda weird.
And then after that, I was like,
every time the air wooshed out,
you kinda smell the rubber a little bit,
and I was like (sniffing)
am I inhaling that white powder?
(laughing)
What is this?
I woke up this morning
and my hip is pretty sore.
So I'd kinda hoped that
the purple would make
more of a difference on that.
But seems like maybe
that's just unavoidable.
- This pillow, since
it was so iffy for me,
I just used it as a pillow that
would accompany my current pillow.
I'd just switch back and forth.
- It wasn't a miracle cure.
Like I would still have some
back soreness in the mornings,
or if I slept on my wrong side,
then I would have hip pain a little bit.
But it drastically reduced
how many times I woke up during the night.
- I mean this could also be
my anti-anxiety medicine,
but I also felt a lot less anxious.
It created a space where I
could just really just relax.
(light happy music)
(wooshing)
(squeaking)